The significant part of the story of my life is my own family.
We came out here, rented places and enjoyed the beach and enjoyed the swimming.
The really remarkable coincidence is that when I married Mary Maxwell,...
...her family had a long tradition of a regular summer stay at...
...Hood Canal, including stays here at Alderbrook where we're sitting today.
We'd swim, play tennis. It was a special thing and now...
...you know, I've got a place where my dad, my sisters and...
...all of dad's grandchildren come out here quite a bit.
So, we're continuing a tradition of time at Hood Canal.
The Cheerio thing was actually just a parallel...
...and an added Hood Canal experience.
When we got together with family, friends and...
...children that came out here for a two weeks stay.
Now, the Cheerio was a group of ten families and...
...so, for a couple of weeks, we'd just be with those other kids and a lot of activities,...
...sports activities, dinners at the other people's house,...
...campfires with skits and singing.
So, I have great memories of growing up here and...
...you know, coming back to the same place year after year,...
...there's a certain predictability and comfort in doing that.
Almost every year, I've been out here and I'll keep doing it.